hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for anime uproar and the final war
in mha has just reached a new massive
milestone the number one pro heroes
suffered a major loss deku's classmates
lives are in direct danger and deku's
impending one for all quirk awakening
could be both the biggest blessing and
the biggest curse for deku horikoshi
really isn't messing around anymore
everything is at stake and things will
never be the same again after this
insane war so let's get into it you guys
know what to do if you enjoy our videos
and you want to see more in the future
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes a second but it really helps with
that youtube algorithm and of course if
you're new or maybe you watch our videos
but you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet remember that subscribing
and hitting that notification bell is
completely free but it really helps me
out a lot finally this video will
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned the previous chapter ended
on a huge cliffhanger shoto was declared
the winner of his battle against dabi
but then we saw a strange light shining
from dobby's chest which made us think
that something big was about to happen
did dobby have a dormant quirk that all
for one had secretly embedded inside of
him kind of like what happened with lady
nagant and that self-destruction quirk
was dobby about to get back into the
fight with this mysterious new quirk or
was he about to explode and kill
everyone around him what was going to
happen next well we don't know because
our boy horikoshi decided to just move
us straight into the fight between all
for one and the top two pro heroes
we begin with hawks explaining that all
for one has a clear weakness the mask
that he is wearing is not just an
accessory it actually contained some
sort of medical apparatus that is
keeping all for one alive even back when
he had escaped from tartarus all for one
was carrying the life support machines
that had been connected to him this
means that his body cannot survive on
its own so that mask is serving as a
sort of life support apparatus and he
needs it to function properly so it goes
without saying that targeting the mask
is a good combat strategy if you can
destroy the mask or at least get the
mask off of him all for one's body will
give out and the battle will be over
however in order to separate over one
from his mask the heroes will have to
get close to him and that presents a
problem all for one has the dangerous
ability to steal quirks if he can touch
you so throwing a bunch of heroes at him
could result in their quirks being
stolen and then added to over one's
already overpowered arsenal and that is
a risk that the heroes simply cannot
take they are already understaffed as it
is so they can't afford to have a bunch
of heroes losing their quirks to all for
one so the heroes made the tactical
decision to attack all for one in a
small group with the two strongest pro
heroes taking on the mission of
defeating him endeavour and hawks are
hoping to combine hawks's incredible
speed with endeavour's amazing firepower
in order to overwhelm over one and take
out his mask but this is all for one
after all so it won't be that easy
especially since hawks's wings are not
yet fully recovered hawks is using
prosthetic wings in order to get
anywhere close to his former speed and
this is obviously not ideal so hawks is
not at 100
hawks tries throwing some flaming
feathers in the direction of all for
one's mask but the villain manages to
evade endeavour then attacks him with a
massive burning fist attack and while
all for one is able to deflect most of
it some of the flaming impact is seeping
through his defenses but even as
endeavour is attacking him all for one
is busy waging psychological warfare he
asks hawks what's wrong because he can
tell that the top two pro heroes are
having trouble coordinating their
attacks according to all for one it is
as if endeavor is feeling a bit off
today all for one is clearly trying to
bring uncertainty and doubt into the
minds of the heroes in order to throw
them off their strategy endeavour tells
hawks not to pay attention and not to
let up because all for one's super
regeneration is already struggling to
keep up with all the damage that their
attacks are doing meanwhile all for one
is still chirping away at endeavour
telling him that all of these heroes and
hero students are giving it their all
and are fully focused on the battle and
yet endeavour's mind seems to be
somewhere else c seems distracted does
he maybe feel bad for his other son toya
does he regret relying on shoto to
defeat toyah instead of taking on that
responsibility himself all for one is
clearly trying to exacerbate all of
endeavour's deepest insecurities and
regrets in order to reduce his
effectiveness in battle it is an
incredibly devious move but it is also
something we've come to expect from all
for one endeavor was doing a good job of
ignoring all for once taunting at first
but then all for one pulls out the big
one looking right in endeavour all for
one says why do you think that little
toya's body was never found as a stunned
look washes over endeavour's face the
terrible truth dawns on him toya's body
was never found because all for one and
the villains found it first and they are
the ones who shaped toya into the
monster that he has become this is only
partially true of course because toyah
ultimately rebelled against the villains
and willingly chose his own path but
endeavour doesn't know the whole story
yet and so his mind is haunted by all
the terrible things that all for one and
the villains must have done to his
helpless son hawks tries to keep
endeavour calm but it's too late
endeavour has lost his cool he rushes at
all for one without thinking and
overwhelm uses this opportunity to rip
off endeavour's arm using his creepy
monster hand thing i don't know what
kind of quirk this is but this looks
like something right out of berserk and
it is extremely creepy
hawks screams out endeavors name and
tries to rush in to save him but this
puts both hawks and the injured endeavor
in full range of all from one's blast
attacks as all for one prepares to
finish them both off hawks and endeavour
are suddenly saved by tokoyami and jiro
using jiro's heartbeat wall jiro was
able to get there in time by flying in
on tokuyami's back and no i will not be
making any jokes about jiro riding
tokoyami okay guys this is a
sophisticated channel for philosophers
anyway hawks is obviously grateful to be
alive but he also yells at the two
students to stay away because the fight
against all for one is way too dangerous
for the two of them but tokuyami insists
that he has what it takes to fight
alongside his mentor hawks after all for
one jokingly calls the students side
characters who only exist to get killed
by the demon lord thereby demonstrating
the demon lord's true power jiro
responds by saying that all for one
should save those kinds of lines until
after he has actually won the fight and
that is how this chapter ends one of the
biggest takeaways from this chapter is
of course the fact that all for one
managed to rip off endeavors right arm
which has the potential to have a major
impact on the entire fight by
manipulating endeavour into losing his
cool and then using that moment to rip
off his arm all for one weakened
endeavor for the rest of the fight now
endeavour won't bleed out because he can
just use his fire to cauterize his own
wound but it's safe to assume that he
won't be as strong as he was before that
said if endeavour survives this fight
he'll just be able to get an advanced
prosthetic like miruko so he'll be fine
in terms of tokoyami and jiro showing up
and interfering in the fight i think
it's good that they did because if they
hadn't both hawks and endeavor might
have been dead by now nevertheless i
also had a similar reaction to hawks it
is extremely dangerous for hero students
to be messing with all for one and both
of these guys just put themselves in
serious risk let's be real some students
could be killed during this war it would
certainly not be unrealistic considering
how strong the villains are and how high
the stakes are so could all for one's
words about the two of them just being
side characters who will get killed by
the demon lord amount to foreshadowing
could tokoyami or jiro die
in this fight if we split class 1a into
tears of importance in terms of the
story these two wouldn't be part of the
top tiers in my opinion even if we take
away deku since he's the protagonist
bakugo todoroki and ochako would be the
next most important tier of students i
would also put kirishimatsuyu and momo
around there probably one tier below
bakugo and the others and then somewhere
after that i would place tokoyami and
jiro although they would still be a tear
above students like ojiro koda and sato
so are these two important yes and
they're definitely important to deku but
are they the most important characters
in 1a definitely not so could one of
them die yes it is possible although i
still think that if any students die
it's going to be students from class 1b
i do think that the potential death of a
classmate would be a massive
life-changing moment for dekku and if
that were to happen deku would enter the
final battle more furious and more
fierce than ever before and speaking of
deku in the final battle a few weeks ago
i speculated what could happen if deku's
own quirk awakened in some unexpected
way during the final battle like for
example if this was triggered by some
tragedy like potentially the death of
all might or maybe one of the classmates
i started thinking about this after the
reveal that shoto was able to awaken his
own quirk in a way that completely
changed how it is able to function by
combining the two different parts of his
quirk into one he was seemingly able to
violate the laws of physics by creating
what is essentially fiery ice i got a
lot of feedback about this so i wanted
to talk about it a bit more because the
loss of endeavour's arm and the direct
involvement of deku's classmates in this
dangerous fight against all for one
really drive home the point that a major
tragedy for the heroes could occur at
any time and if it does happen it will
surely break deku because he couldn't be
there to stop it so after seeing shoto
awakening the ability to fuse both
distinct parts of his quirk into a
single entity an entity that seems to
defy the laws of physics i started
wondering whether something similar
could happen to deku with one for all
what if a tragic event during this war
triggers deku's quirk awakening and then
all of the distinct quirks that he
possesses suddenly fuse into a single
ability a quirk singularity if dr
uchiko's theories about quirk
singularity are correct and they do
appear to be then upon achieving one for
all quirk singularity deku could lose
control of his body and essentially go
berserk especially if this ultimate
power-up comes as a result of some
emotional trauma like the death of
someone close to him shigaraki's own
body has already been adapting to the
challenges of quirk singularity and his
body is now able to literally mutate in
order to accommodate many different
quirks for example we recently seen his
new ability to generate thousands of
fingers from his body and this ability
doesn't come from a quirk but from his
body itself however shigaraki is able to
do this because his body was heavily
modified by uchiko's procedures deku's
body does not have those alterations so
if the quirks of one for all were to
suddenly combine and attain quirk
singularity deku's body would have to
adapt to all of this power on his own we
already know that one for all is a
stockpiling quirk that has been getting
stronger from generation to generation
and its core has been expanding as well
deku is the first one for all user who
can actually access the quirk factors of
all the previous users in order to
actually use their quirks and this is
also an indication that one for all has
been evolving rapidly in recent years
the big question is what would a one for
all awakening look like what would this
quark singularity mean for deku and his
power i believe that just like the two
distinct aspects of shoto's quirk merged
into one all the different quirks that
deku possesses as part of one for all
will also merge into a single quirk so
he will no longer need to make the
conscious decision to use vajin or float
or black whip he will suddenly gain a
new form that allows him to seamlessly
use all of them together without even
thinking about it because all of them
will become a single integral part of
this new insane form this new form will
make deku both faster and stronger but
it will also likely challenge his
ability to actually control his body his
body which hasn't received treatment
from ujico will be pushed to its limit
and he may even lose control temporarily
and just go berserk like the hulk i
imagine that just like shigaraki's body
began to mutate once it started adapting
to the quirk singularity deku's body
will also start mutating although not in
the same way as shigaraki with all those
creepy fingers deku's mutation could go
in a variety of directions but in my
mind i imagine deku becoming buff like
the hulk but with red skin as an
indicator of his surging power and
righteous rage
this is just my own imagination though
that could be coming like an out of
control red hulk and i'm sure that none
of you guys who are watching this video
are going to start trolling anime onlys
by saying things like oh man red deku is
so overpowered just wait until you see
red deku get animated and so on you guys
would never do that i'm sure to me
personally it just makes sense for all
the different parts of one for all to
one day unite into a single overpowered
form like the two sides of shoto's quirk
uniting into one although one for all is
even more powerful and has more quirks
to work with so we're probably gonna see
shoto's awakening times 10 with deku and
this one for all quirk singularity will
end up clashing with shigaraki's all for
one quirk singularity in the ultimate
final battle of the series do you guys
agree with me will deku obtain an
awakened final form as all the one for
all quirks merge into one and will this
form turn out to be crucial for
defeating shigaraki if so what do you
think will trigger this transformation
will it just happen organically or will
it be triggered by some emotional
tragedy like the death of a character
who is close to deku could tokoyami jiro
or another hero student die during this
arc or maybe an important hero like
endeavor or almight finally is red deku
stronger than goku let me know down
below
if you guys enjoyed this video leave a
quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it helps me out with that
youtube algorithm and of course if
you're new to anime pro or maybe you
watch our videos but you just haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet do me a
quick favor and make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications it is
a completely free way to directly
support the channel in a real way right
now you can also hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime opera
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime outpour patrons for making
videos like this one possible special
thank you to kyle salisbury this man is
an absolute mad lad and a disciple of
lord twigo himself and i can't forget
all of our the one tier patrons the ones
who rise above all other clans including
alpha sigma pate heffa the red-haired
fox hinokamian water the toasted chi
corey mcgowan the fallen chosen orihime
wukong dante tinel and big buddhist
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh angel cruz alicia octor bonnie
parks fat boy games kaido might be a
duck alivania and anime s codem if you
guys enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value to you consider
supporting us on patreon as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys